we got the PhD from University of
Maryland he is now assisting professor
Duke University he also spent a year he
spent a year at as a postdoc researcher
at VMI research and how do I know that
because I was well I was also there at
the time you actually managed to make it
a little funny
all right good afternoon everyone so
today I'll be talking about flexible
Byzantine fault tolerance which in a
nutshell is a new approach to designing
BFD solutions so at its core it has two
key strengths one is it reduces the
notion of diversity and the second is
the notion of stronger resilience so
what do I mean by diversity so in the
previous talk and talks in the morning
we heard of everyone saying we need this
delta bound symphony to hold
we also heard someone saying that we
should not assume any Delta I think the
last speaker and in the previous session
said that so generally we assume
Byzantine faults I think David mentioned
yesterday that we should assume safety
faults and liveness faults so all of you
have your own beliefs you have your own
assumptions don't worry we have one
protocol that will satisfy all of you so
diversity over here means you can use
the same ledger you can have your own
assumptions and yet you can coexist so
far as the assumptions are correct under
the actual system that's so very
abstractly yes so nakamoto so it is in
line with that philosophy at a very very
abstract level yes and stronger
resilience just means that we can
tolerate a higher number of faults then
what is known and no we are not breaking
any lower bounds over here so let me put
this in context so we are thinking of a
state machine replication system and
here is how I'll use a consensus
protocol in such a system you have a
server who is maintaining a state
machine and you have multiple clients
who are sending commands to this server
the whole of the server is to take these
commands order them log them and then
then execute them one by one on the
street machine so if you have a server
that never fails it's never faulty
there's actually an ideal world to live
in but unfortunately we have to deal
with 40 servers which is why one
solution that state machine replication
suggests is to use multiple such server
replicas and should have a single non
quality server the guarantee you get
over here is that a group of servers
will provide you with the same interface
as that of a single non faulty server
and this holds even if some of the
servers are faulty for example the
server on the bottom right there's 40 in
this world you have these clients
sending commands to the server replicas
now the server replicas first need to
engage in a consensus protocol to agree
on a sequence of values and then they'll
execute them on the state machine one by
one
more precisely you require two
guarantees which was I think Ling also
mentioned in this in the previous talk
one is called safety and the other is
lightness safety says that any tune on
faulty service should learn or execute
the same sequence of values and
lightness is a value proposed by a
client will eventually be executed by
aeverine on 40 so so with this in mind
let us see how classical concepts
protocols are used today so there will
be an administrator who will assume who
will make some assumptions on what your
network is for example he can make a
symphony assumption he can make a
partial synchrony assumption then he'll
decide what the network delay Delta is
so there was a lot of there were a lot
of comments on what Delta can be in the
talk in the morning and this is
something that that means administrator
has to set ahead of time if he decides
to make a if he decides to use the
synchronous protocol
he can decide how many faults he wants
to tolerate a minority corruption 1/3
falls once of thoughts and so on and so
forth
so once he picks one set of parameters
he'll go through he'll go to the
consensus literature and try to find the
best consensus protocol to use for
example if you pick partials and Connie
and one-third faults perhaps he picks
pbft and once you have this the system
is deployed all the clients using the
system need to agree with the
assumptions that Dartmouth administrator
makes so here are some concerns with
this approach so existing consensus
protocols are optimized for tolerating a
large number of Byzantine faults
for example partial asynchronous
protocols can tolerate or third faults
simplest protocols can tolerate a half
faults and these are actually optimal in
terms of the number of bits so basically
it needs to agree in the sense of if it
believes that there are a large number
of faults than let's say you as
impartial synchrony and one-third faults
and if the client believes that there
are actually 40% faults then the system
is not usable from the perspective of
the flight so if it wants to use the
system it has to be the the beliefs are
imposed on the right
so these protocols are optimized for
Byzantine ports and in fact they are
optimal but the question is something
what I think David was asking yesterday
this Byzantine fault the predominant
adversary that we are concerned about
the second concern is that over here the
administrator makes all assumptions and
these assumptions are imposed upon the
clients in practice you can have clients
who have external knowledge about the
system or the same client under
different situations may have different
beliefs for example if I'm buying the
coffee I do not believe that's an
adversity who's trying to attack me but
if I'm trying to sell my house and get a
million dollars perhaps the adversary
gains by the having a safety violation
so the question is can we support
multiple clients making different
assumptions and finally there are no
recovery mechanisms so if the
administrator assumptions are incorrect
all client commits fail so the question
is can be support recovery mechanisms in
case the come your permits are in cut
so with flexible BFD which we think is
one consensus protocol for the populace
we try to address these concepts first
we introduce this notion of a live but
corrupt fault so an alive but corrupt
fault is an adversary that tries to
attack your safety but not your likeness
so this is an adversity whose only are
trying to attack your safety one can
think of it as a rational adversary
whose utility function is maximized if
he creates a safety violation and we
refer to this as an ABC part and the
total number of faults in the system is
the total number of Byzantine faults you
have plus the total number of ABC faults
you have and it is in that sense that we
say we can tolerate a larger number of
words
second we support client diversity
instead of make adversary making all
assumptions inflexible BFD we try to
separate the fault model from the actual
solution so we have one solution or one
ledger and every client can make his own
assumption and decide how to interpret
the ledger so for example the client can
decide whether it wants to live in a
synchronous world or a partially
synchronous world or the type and the
number of faults you have and if you are
living in a sense miss world water Delta
is so for example you can have a client
which wants to tolerate 33 percent
Byzantine faults and know ABC faults and
living in a partial synchrony world who
simultaneously exists with a client for
example who wants to tolerate 33 percent
Byzantine faults 33 percent ABC faults
and living in a synchronous world so
these numbers are not quite arbitrary of
course there are some restrictions that
the clients need to follow and it is so
for one parameterization this is what
the restriction looks like so on the
x-axis you have the fraction of
Byzantine faults you can tolerate and on
the y-axis you have the fraction of
total number of words which is Byzantine
plus ABC faults that you can tolerate
and one point on this graph refers to
one client belief orange region are the
clients that we can support in a
partially synchronous Network and the
green region are the clients that we can
support in a synchronous Network and the
three clients that I'm referring to are
just three points in the space
and finally of course if they give
clients so much power then they can make
an incorrect assumption and if a client
makes an incorrect assumption and fails
we give you restricts on what it can do
to recover by picking safer assumptions
in the future
all right so since we're thinking of
clients with different assumptions it
turns out the definition that I came up
with earlier do not quite apply and that
is basically because you can have
clients who have incorrect assumptions
so earlier we said for safety you want
any two learners are ready to serve
replicas to learn the same sequence of
values and for likeness you said a value
proposed by a proposer will eventually
be executed by every learner and since
all assumptions were the same you can
think of your replicas as being your
learners and they can commit to values
in a new model clients have different
assumptions so we have the same
guarantees of safety and liveness that
whole but they hold only for clients
with correct assumptions the assumptions
can be different but so far as they are
correct you will have safety and
liveness and in this world because
replicas do not know what client
assumptions are you think of clients as
visual learners and not replicas
so me that's this one the proposal did
not be one with the correct assumption
in that case I would think of a proposal
as being a client or a learner as well
it's just two different rules for the
same if he wants to learn the final
value of commit then yes and the learner
role will do it for him the proposal
will be eventually executed rather than
the different issue one is completely
and other it's not I think the
distinction probably is you do not want
any sort of censorship once something is
raised is it is comes in the proposal
can be straw in both you because now it
changes inside not the next thing that
what is this but if - not this if I see
what it is I'll change it so it's not
general this is just I don't see why you
can't live with something simpler which
is the new things will be perhaps I
think I'd be happy to chart maybe after
after the talk the distinction between
the two because I'm I did not quite that
but I'll be able to chart in the break
or so what is on the change is that it
somebody proposed but you may be
different forever so why might put this
as part of them of the condition it's a
stronger condition you can live without
it
why might I care about you but the
system doesn't care about you once all
right
what's wrong with it as long as the
system focuses but the system does not
have emotional commits what the system
does not have an open up comment and
make enormous sum value proposed by some
propose there will be eventually goes by
proposes sorrow you mean Sam proposal
you know any proposal yeah executed by
aluminum so proposals here is what's
called a good name it's not the point
it's not a particular proposal name I'm
sorry I don't quite get you but in the
interest of time I'd be happy to discuss
this after my talk
all right so at a technical level we
want again diversity and stronger
resilience but what does diversity mean
they want to target different clients
what does that mean in the synchronous
world we want clients to pick what
whatever value of delta that they want I
can say messages arrive within one
second and David may say messages may
arrive in the next ten seconds right
it's not just with respect to this
particular times its name yes so you
could have given more diversity by
allowing thinking networking they
respected you perhaps but I think you
would need the network quite delay
anyway at least for the solution to work
and second the clients can pick the
number of faults and also the type of
faults in terms of ABC's and Byzantine
adversaries and in terms of stronger
resilience all we want is to tolerate
more faults
so to tackle the first scenario of
clients with different deltas we have a
new simplest BFD protocol where replicas
execute at what is called network speed
I'll get to that in the next slide and
to tolerate different kinds of faults
and more number of faults we introduced
this new notion of flexible Byzantine
chorim's so we understand how quorums
work in specific settings for example in
a pbft style protocol and we introduce
what is called a flexible Byzantine coil
so in the interest of time today I'll
focus only on the left hand side
ABC faults are weaker than the Byzantine
focus so if the whole point is till your
Disney follows another person even if
you claim it is to coordinate both parts
then basically water system can actually
study any person to the visiting because
if you're 30
yes the stronger when their protocol
depends is on 33% all right
not really because your ABC faults can
try to kill your say ABC party so ABC
faults contribute only to safety
violations yes so and so do Byzantine
faults steam fault you increase your
number of ABC pots that does not change
you can keep them to 30% bounded but
it's ultimately the bins default is what
is going to change the whole protocol
that is columns were produced dependent
on so I'll give you a simple example
where you have 0% Byzantine faults no
and no no how many of our Byzantine
faults you want and let's say give you
have 80% ABC faults I can show a very
simple scenario where you can see a
safety violation without using any of
the positive words
if you have 33% visiting person then you
cannot increase I mean yeah okay so
you're basically saying if I'm a client
and if I am in a very specific
instantiation where I have 33% Byzantine
force I cannot tolerate more ABC for its
you're right it depends on what exact
parameterize ation we have so I do not
have that slide over here but I'll be
very happy to talk about it alright so a
synchronous BFP protocol with network
speed replicas so if you see in any
synchronous protocol executed here is a
figure that you will usually see you
have horizontal order lines representing
different parties or different replicas
and you have vertical lines representing
rounds of the protocol and but
synchronous protocols these rounds are
two Delta long generally and in
particular they're replicas need to know
what this value of Delta is so that they
know when to participate in a particular
protocol so are over here since clients
are picking these Delta values we do not
want the replicas to know what this
bounded delay is so the replicas want
should execute a synchronous protocol
without knowing what Delta is yes how
this will work your client will submit a
command the replicas will engage in some
protocol some communication and and
reach a state and eventually there will
be yet another client who will come in
and say for this command if my bounded
delay was a delta one does it committed
and the replicas should give our yes/no
response to the client so in a sense
this BFP protocol is a synchronous
protocol where only your commit step
requires the knowledge of Delta and
otherwise you never use Delta at all and
this is what enables us to allow
multiple clients with different values
of Delta
so for simplicity so in our paper for of
course for the synchronous part we
assume Symphony for synchronous clients
and that is a message sent at time T
will arrive by time t plus delta and in
this presentation in addition I'm going
to assume that we have a single short
version of the protocol that is we are
not doing this on a sequence of values
widget but just for one value and we are
also going to assume a fixed known delta
but you can easily relax this for
different clients with different elders
and for now I'm also assuming only
Byzantine and honest parties that is
there is that is you have only a
minority corruption and there are no ABC
faults but again this can be relaxed to
tolerate ABC faults as well
so here is what the protocol looks like
at a high level you have three different
replicas for example and let's say one
of them is a leader the leader will
propose a value B and it will arrive at
different topic cause perhaps at
different points in time and a replica
whenever it receives a value it will
vote for the first valid value it hears
okay so replica three as soon as it
hears B it will vote for it
and similarly replica one and two will
vote for the values these boats we are
going to assume also act as re proposals
of the original proposal so we assume
implicitly over here everything is
digitally signed so you're also
forwarding the proposal along with your
wood and your committee will is
something very simple
after I vote I will wait for two Delta
time so let us assume as a thought
process we know a value Delta over here
and so assuming that so after I would
I'll wait for two Delta time and if I
see no equivocating value or no
conflicting value then I'll commit to
this block and in the main execution of
the protocol it's as simple as this so
why does it suffice for me to commit
after two Delta time if I see no
equivocation
so I'm going to claim that if I observe
no conflicting value then two things
hold one value B will be certified that
is it will be signed by a majority of
honest replicas and second I'm also
going to show that no conflicting value
will be certified if there was no equal
vocation seen by the party who is
committing the argument is actually very
simple so so let's say replica one is
the one who is committing over here then
we can say the following let's say a
replica one votes at time T and let's
say it is committing at time t plus 2
delta if it votes at time t then at t
plus at time t plus delta everyone will
hear the word or everyone will also hear
the repose 'l sent by this replica and
if there was indeed no equivocation
everyone would have voted for this block
and at t plus 2 delta it will be
certified because all the honest with
applicants will vote for it now let us
try to argue why no conflicting value
will be certified let us say an
equivocation did exist let us try to
find at what point in time some honest
replicas must have voted for it an
honest replica received an equivocation
somewhere in between T plus Delta and T
plus 2 Delta observe that it will not
vote for something like this and the
reason why it will not do it is because
the first honest word that you received
is that T plus Delta and this arrived
afterwards on the flipside if it
appeared in between t and t plus delta
or in general any time before t plus
delta it would indeed vote for something
what for that conflicting value but in
that case replica one would have heard
of it within p plus 2 delta after the
water
so all of this works so far as your if a
leader does indeed honest all of this
will book if your leader equivocate
sends conflicting values of course we
need to tackle that we'll have to engage
in some protocol to blame the leader
detect equivocation and engage in a
wheel change protocol that is changing
the leader so I'll explain I'll sketch
at a high level how this works but
probably not going to the details of the
analysis so if you want to change the
leader then at some point in time a new
leader is going to appear and it has to
propose a new value to four to everyone
so that everyone can commit to it and
the key is that if someone has committed
to some value let's say to a value B in
the previous iteration then it is
required that the new leader proposes
the same value that it committed to that
is the requirement you have and this new
leader may not know what happened
earlier
so if a new leader is honest one
requirement that you have is that it
needs to know what to propose on the
other hand if your new leader is
Byzantine you do not want it to propose
a wrong value and get away with it so
the way we tackle this is for the honest
new leader at the end of the view
everyone sends the status of assigned
status of what happened in the previous
iteration and the new leader can then
know if someone has committed it will
know that this is the value I need to
propose and then it can propose but so
that a Byzantine leader does not cheat
we end up giving it some making it send
some proof along with a proof of Status
Messages
so that it does not cheat and a proof
over here essentially is a set of F plus
one statuses that you receive or 51%
statuses that you receive from all
replicas
so
you're thinking of over here the the
minority corruption scenario so you are
tolerating F out of 2 f plus 1 faults so
observe that you cannot expect the
leader to send more than F plus 1
statuses because Byzantine parties may
not send their statuses on the flip side
over here a Byzantine leader can pick
whichever F plus 1 at wants so f of them
can be a Byzantine and you can only
expect it to send 1 on a status so what
you want is if someone has just
committed all honest need to endorse
this value so that safety holds so at
the end of view in the status message
you want all honest to support an honest
commit and send us and send a
certificate endorsing it and it turns
out the way we tackle this is by
changing the commit rule to something a
little different we say you start your
to Delta time but instead of starting
after sending your wood you start it
after you actually receive a certificate
so that after that if a you change
happens at any point in time you have
this certificate that you can send to
the new leader so because I do not have
time perhaps I'll not go into the
details of this but trust me this just
works
so okay over here we assumed in our
analysis that you have a fixed time
Delta but observe that you use this time
Delta only when you commit to a value
not anytime before that and even in the
view change protocol we never used this
time Delta to do any weights so and that
is why you can live in a world where a
client sends commands and you end up
doing all execution except for this EQ
vocation check and if you ever receive
an equivalent you can just maintain some
data some data on when equivocations
arrived and correspondingly respond to
clients and this is how we can tolerate
or we can provision different clients
with different deltas
so our second contribution was
introducing this notion of flexible
Byzantine quorums I'll sketch a very
high-level view of what this is trying
to say so in general with if you looked
at any talks on partial simcha in fact
even bharden ellis cose talked yesterday
morning referred to this in the first
set of slides so in partial synchrony
you and you use three F plus one but
replicas and the way you analyze this is
to say I'm going to use a quorum of size
two F plus one so if 2 f plus 1 replicas
tell me to do something I can go ahead
and do it so if 2 f plus 1 replicas tell
me to commit I will commit to that value
and intuitively the reason why it's ok
we argue is because there does not exist
another set of two F plus 1 at replicas
that will make my commit unsafe and the
reason why it does not exist is because
there will be F plus one replicas in the
intersection where F of them can be
Byzantine and one of them will be an
honest replica who will not say two
different things to different honest
replicas now you may wonder why is this
3 F plus 1 to F plus 1 s plus 1 so 3 X
plus 1 is because of lower bounds that
say you cannot tolerate a large number
of faults the reason why you have to F
plus 1 or 2 F plus 1 replicas in the
Quran this because you want to have an
honest intersection of F plus 1 if you
reduce that your intersection will not
have an honest replica on the flip side
you cannot increase that either because
out of 3 F plus 1 F of them could be
Byzantine and they will not respond to
you so you cannot have a quorum size
larger than 2 X plus 1 but instead of
having all Byzantine faults indeed if
you have ABC faults my n is 3 M plus 5
then indeed the two things we can get /
- right
yes yes yes yes you can so I'm yeah I'm
kind of hard coding it over here yes
so if you have ABC poles indeed we can
ask this question of what can I do with
a larger quorum size because you have
ABC faults who are going to respond to
your values they try to attack your
safety but not your likeness and it
turns out you have with the larger
quorum you can actually have a higher
fault tolerance yes
but I think you get the point you want a
logic Odom yeah so over here in that
sense you will get high fault tolerance
so for reasons that we analyzed in the
paper turns out only one of these two
chorim's can be larger the other one
cannot be but probably I will not go
into the details in this protocol in
this talk so we saw at a high level a
sink EFT protocol with network speed
replicas and one of the key things over
here was it was Delta agnostic for the
most part and similarly with flexible
Byzantine currents that you can use with
partials and partially synchronous
protocols such as pbft again you don't
need a delta assumption and actually
both of these protocols turns out are
very similar to each other so in a sense
we can actually combine them in a neat
way to achieve one protocol that
tolerates clients with many different
assumptions and that is what we do with
flexible BFD
so just to put this in context with
existing work again we have over here in
this graph the fraction of Byzantine
faults you are tolerating and on the
y-axis we have the fraction of total
faults that we are tolerating and the
different lines over here represent
different instantiations that you can
have with flexible BFD so for example if
I instantiate this in the way a standard
pbft protocol does where you expect 67%
of votes to arrive then it is
represented by this line and this
reference by the Green Line and it is
referred to as Q R equals 0.67 over here
and in terms of clients you can tolerate
for partial synchrony you can tolerate
all clients below this line with with
those specific assumptions and for
simplest clients you can tolerate the
one with this dot over here and this is
also the figure that I showed earlier if
I compare this with existing protocols
for partially synchronous protocols you
can think of them as being one
particular fault model over here which
is this cross and similarly for
synchronous protocols and as one
particular point over here which
tolerates 0.5 Byzantine faults and 0.5
total for that is no additional ABC
faults
and to conclude when can we use this we
can use this in different scenarios one
is when you have different kinds of
transactions for example you have a
coffee transaction versus a
million-dollar house transaction
you can use this when there is a client
who is making a synchrony assumption and
he knows that there is some network
outage because of which simply does not
hold anymore and at that point it can
switch to a partially synchronous
assumption based on its external
knowledge and similarly if you observe
some sort of an equivocation a client
can change its beliefs to tolerate a
higher number of faults because it sees
an active attack that is happening in
the network
so with that here are my collaborators
Dalian Lane and can be happy to
[Applause]
so it is essentially the safety fault
that you want to tolerate so anyone who
is willing to send equivocating values
to different replicas is an alive but
corrupt failure
I wouldn't they should do whatever
maximizes their utility function in this
case we are defining the utility
function as creating a safety violation
if they can they will try to
so they've said that but if they said a
clever thing including messages this can
easily be detected by somebody else
maybe so isn't this something stupid for
them sure but on the flip side if you
think of this as if they're going to get
a million dollars out of it they may not
care anyway if they've so if you want to
consider crash failures here in there
are synchronous sense will it be too
difficult except axles were should be I
think we should be able to do that so
this is already some work for example
except he does something like that and
we should be able to do something like
that over here as well
so I can have the greatest we've done
some welcome contains either isms and
optimization very headlight these are
the in Falls and symmetric faults and
emission forces on all in pictures in
the picture this is like long term since
independence no very fine can say what
and the faults how many Poles you you
can tolerate and it's also servants told
in dependability community for some long
time that in something decent eNOS
option is very general but it's also
very internet costly so it more
processes which it's more possible
faults and sort of its might not be the
best way to follow a trench phones but
just say okay everything every
misbehavior is actually visiting for so
much more fine-grained
all right in that case I'll mind the
next